in the wake of the mass hysteria that
was the january 6th riots at the u.s
capitol
a lot of people felt something anything
had to be done
and social media was the immediate first
target first president trump was banned
from using facebook and twitter
then google and apple made the decision
to remove parlor from their app stores
some build parlor as a bastion of free
speech in light moderation others said
it would cater to conservative voices
others just said it was filled with hate
speech but the companies justified their
actions in removing parlor by noting
that parlor was used to
both incite and organize events that
unfolded at the capitol on january 6th
what else was i supposed to do the guy i
wanted to win
didn't win and it all came to a head
when amazon decided to suspend parlor's
access to their web services platform
in taking down this harmless right-wing
alternative to facebook millions of
individuals
were left with no means of sharing their
legitimate political views or plans to
organize peaceful protests
without the oversight and intrusion of
facebook and twitter's clearly biased
fact checkers
and haters of free speech at least
that's what
some people want you to believe
[Music]
brought to you by mac weldon hey legal
eagles it's time to think like a
corporate lawyer
because parlor is suing amazon for
getting kicked off of the aws platform
but what was the basis for amazon to
abruptly suspend the use of their web
services by this ultra-conservative
twitter clone
did they break their agreement with
parlor or even worse is there a
conspiracy between amazon and twitter to
nuke the competition
and what does this all have to do with
the first amendment and let's talk about
the public version of why parlor got
suspended
amazon and parlor had a contract
detailing each party's rights and
responsibilities
parlor was allowed to use amazon as its
web host but only if it agreed to follow
some basic rules including moderating
content
so why did amazon suspend parlor's web
services
well both companies agree that parlor's
lacks moderation policies have been an
ongoing source of conflict between these
two companies
since at least november of last year now
all internet hosting companies have
rules of the road about what content is
and is not allowed
amazon and twitter seem to have more
stringent standards about what content
gets posted to their website platforms
parlor on the other hand takes a more
complicated approach to handling
complaints
parlor relied on juries of its own users
to determine whether an offensive post
broke its own rules crowdsourcing
adjudication of complaints
proved to be really slow how slow well
at the time the amazon booted parlor
there was a backlog of 26
000 complaints that parlor juries had
yet to adjudicate
and on november 17 2020 seven weeks
before the insurrectionist storm the
capital
amazon emailed parlor to highlight some
of the violent posts that were made on
its services
one post derided michelle obama using
racist words in response
another user said the only good democrat
is a dead one kill em all
a representative of parlor replied to
the post hateful as it is
would not be deemed a violation of our
terms and service
amazon essentially told parlor that this
was a problem because parlor either did
not care to or they simply did not have
an effective way
to comply with the amazon web service
company's terms of service
including moderating violent rhetoric
the issue came to a head
after the deadly riots of the capital
when violent and threatening posts
continued to go unchecked by
parlor despite multiple parlays between
amazon and parlor
the violent post increased with only
half-hearted responses
being provided by parlor to increase
their moderation efforts by using more
volunteers
and on january 9th parlor was notified
by amazon web services that at 11
59 pm on sunday january 10th they would
stop providing web services for the
website and app
for a week parlor services were
completely down with only recent signs
of reappearing
now when apple and google removed the
parlor app from their respective app
stores
no one could download the app but the
data was still there and it could be
migrated elsewhere
but with amazon going down not only
could parlor not obtain new users
but the users they currently had could
no longer use parlor at
all as a result parlor filed a lawsuit
in federal court on january 11th
seeking a temporary restraining order or
tro against amazon in the hopes of
either preventing amazon from removing
them from their web services
or if that went through putting them
back on the aws platform
so let's dig into this lawsuit starting
with the complaint that parlor filed
against
amazon it contains three causes of
action or
court thingies that it says that amazon
has done wrong
and what's as interesting as the three
causes of action that are included are
the ones that are not included
there is nothing in this complaint about
the first amendment
why because that's not actually a thing
as we've talked about
many times on this channel the first
amendment doesn't apply to
individual people citizens or private
companies
it stops the government from restricting
or mandating speech
of its citizens so as a result
parlor doesn't include a cause of action
against amazon under the first amendment
because that's not really a thing but
the first cause of action that parlor
research relates to the sherman
antitrust act
and the sherman antitrust act is just
about as misunderstood as the first
amendment but at least
the antitrust act is a real legal thing
that you are allowed to claim
and parlor claims that amazon web
services is in cahoots with twitter
and conspired to de-platform parlor to
effectively remove them as a competitor
parlor claims this violates section 1 of
the sherman antitrust act
the federal statute which prohibits
activities that restrict interstate
commerce and competition
in the marketplace and here's the big
thing that most people don't understand
about the sherman antitrust act and
antitrust laws in general which is that
in the u.s
it's not illegal to be a really big
company you see
ge owns kitchen all of colorado which in
turn owns jmi of stanford which is a
majority shareholder in
pokerfastlane.com which recently
acquired the sheinhardt wig company
which owns nbc
outright nbc owns winnipeg ironworks
which owns the optionagi party meets
corporation of pyongyang north korea
it's not even illegal to be a monopoly
or monopsony that alone
is not illegal but what is illegal under
antitrust laws is using your market
powers to get an
unfair advantage and the number one
thing
you can't do the reason antitrust laws
existed
in the first place is conspire with a
bunch of other companies to
root out the competition that's what a
cartel is it's a group of companies who
conspire together for
an unfair advantage and there are a
bunch of other improper things that are
made illegal by the sherman antitrust
act but what's relevant here is section
one
and in order to prove a violation of
section one of the sermon antitrust act
basically requires proof of one the
existence of an actual conspiracy to
intention on the part of those
co-conspirators to restrain trade
and three actual injury to the
competition and to support this claim
parlor alleges the following facts
number one
amazon web services and twitter signed a
multi-year agreement
for twitter's use of amazon web services
in december of 2020
to on january 8 twitter banned president
trump giving an opportunity for parlor
to gain a large number of disgruntled
twitter users including trump himself
and three less than 24 hours after
trump's twitter ban amazon
indefinitely banned parlor from using
its web services
amazon's response was that these
allegations don't meet the basic
threshold requirement for a sherman
antitrust act
now the supreme court has long held that
a complaint alleging a violation of the
sherman antitrust act
must provide quote enough factual matter
taken as true to suggest that an
agreement was made however as amazon
pointed out in responding briefs
parlor does not even claim that twitter
and aws communicated about parlor much
less
formed an agreement and in fact parlor
didn't present any evidence direct or
circumstantial
that shows that there was an actual
conspiracy or intent on the part of
twitter
and amazon to restrain parlor's business
now
conspiracy doesn't require an explicit
contract between the two
but parlor doesn't actually provide any
evidence that any agreement or meeting
of the minds
no matter how informal was actually made
or that any communications took place
whatsoever
moreover the supreme court has
explicitly held that if a business has
an independent business justification
for its conduct
and there's no basis for rejecting that
justification as a legitimate
explanation
the case will be dismissed for example
when sprint was sued for allegedly
colluding with other carriers to raise
text message prices
a court dismissed the claim even though
text messaging prices
went up throughout the entire
telecommunications industry sprint had
or claimed to have an independent
business justification for raising per
message prices
the company wanted to push more
subscribers to purchase bundled calling
and text plans
the court found that this was a
legitimate justification and one that
all the telecom companies shared a
desire to push people toward buying
bundled services there wasn't any proof
that sprint even played a leadership
role in increasing per message pricing
nor
was there enough evidence to show that
the telecom companies colluded amongst
each other to do everything
in concert and here parlor alleges that
amazon's motivation for taking its
action was political and that it had no
legitimate business reasons for
terminating the agreement
and parlor goes back towards the
conspiracy idea asserting that
amazon wanted to benefit twitter but
parlor didn't make a single allegation
that conversations were held between
twitter and amazon regarding parlor
let alone they had some master plan in
place to jointly stifle twitter's
competition
and even if amazon had acted
unilaterally for the benefit of twitter
that still would not be enough for an
antitrust action again
without the conspiracy element being
satisfied an allegation of violating the
sherman antitrust act
falls on its face of course what was
more plausible between amazon and
twitter and frankly apple and google at
the same time
is something referred to as conscious
parallelism conscious parallelism is the
undisclosed imitation
of another business action this includes
things like gas stations across the
street from each other
mimicking each other's prices or
telecoms all raising the price of text
messages
the same was likely the case with the
wave of responses to parlor in the wake
of the capital rights
as one company realized they needed to
cut ties with this company
others without discussion or conspiracy
simply decided they needed to follow
suit to both protect their business
interests and prevent future similar
events
basically everyone realized that parlor
was toxic at exactly the same time
because of everything that happened now
that takes us to the second cause of
action for
breach of contract and of course i saved
the breach of contract allegation for
the middle of the video because as we
all know
contract law is the sexiest of all laws
that's right i'm bringing sexy contract
now the basic premise of this allegation
is twofold first that amazon's
suspension was really a termination for
an alleged material breach
and second any termination for cause due
to a purported material breach
required a 30-day notice and cure period
to
fix the breaches which was not provided
now let's just start off by giving
parlor the benefit of the doubt here
that amazon suspension was in fact a de
facto termination
the clause of the agreement that parlor
hangs their argument on states quote
either party may terminate this
agreement for
cause if the other party is in material
breach of this agreement
and the material breach remains uncured
for a period of 30 days from the receipt
of notice
by the other party now unfortunately for
parlor you can't pick and choose what
portion of the agreement makes your
argument seem more plausible
the customer agreement with amazon also
contains a broader right to terminate an
agreement
without requiring a 30-day cure period
in that same section referenced by
parlor in its complaint
the amazon web services customer
agreement gives specific unilateral
right to amazon to quote
terminate this agreement immediately
upon notice to you for
cause if we have the right to suspend
under section six and section six allows
for suspension for any conduct by the
customer
or its user that's in breach of the
agreement so the whole premise of
parlor's argument
is basically blown to pieces as
referenced in their complaint a breach
of contract requires the
contract imposes a duty the duty is
breached and the breach proximately
causes damages to the claimant
in the present instance though the
alleged duty a 30-day notice was
a straw man of sorts it didn't matter if
amazon gave
them one day notice or no notice at all
per the terms of the agreement that
parlor signed amazon had a separate
unilateral right to terminate the
agreement immediately for conduct
that was in breach of the agreement now
at the same time a lot of people have
looked at this contract and said gee
this contract seems
super one-sided it gives amazon a ton of
power and it seems like they can
terminate anyone for almost any reason
and
people are right that's how these
contracts are often written
and companies are considered to be
sophisticated business players and they
can contract to basically whatever they
want as long as it's not against
public policy and here amazon had a
contract it's probably the same contract
that it uses for everyone that hosts web
content with them
and parlor had the option not to sign
the contract but
they chose to and so they're bound by it
just as much as amazon is
amazon just had the foresight to write
the contract that they wanted
so let's talk about if parlor was in
breach of the contract and
really these kind of fights are won and
lost based on what's in the contract not
based on
generally the action that is undertaken
after the contract is signed so you can
probably guess how this is going to turn
out
so we have to ask did parlor breach the
agreement and the answer that is
probably simple
they hosted a ton of content that
advocated violence against a variety of
individuals along with other notable
illegal content
and they repeatedly failed to remove it
by parlor's own admission
there was a backlog of 26 000 reports of
content that violated its community
standards
yet remained on the website and as a
result individuals were able to incite
and coordinate
various aspects of the january 6th
attack on the us capitol boom
lawyer and what a lot of people think is
worse is that following
the horrific event the violent and legal
content actually seemed to increase on
parlor with no sign of slowing down
and section 4.2 makes clear that the
customer is responsible to quote
ensure that their content and their end
users use
of their content or the service
offerings will not violate any of the
policies or any applicable law
the customer is quote solely responsible
for the development content operation
maintenance and use
of its content and in addition section
4.5 of the customer agreement states
that if you become aware of any
violation
of your obligations under this agreement
caused by an end user you will
immediately suspend
access to your content and the service
offerings by such
end user so what obligations may those
be
well the agreement itself states that
the customer is responsible to
immediately remove and suspend end users
and content that pose a security risk
to the service offerings or any third
party appendix 3 soft limits
with you and in addition as part of the
agreement parlor agreed to abide by
amazon's acceptance use policy which
prohibits certain content
including the content that violates the
rights of others or that may be harmful
to others
so the question is was there a breach of
contract
well based on all of the available
evidence it certainly seems so
it's just that the breach of contract
was not by amazon
it was probably by parlor in that they
had recklessly violated the terms of the
agreement which resulted
in a what seems like justifiable
suspension
of those services and finally that takes
us to the third claim in the complaint
for intentional interference with
prospective economic
advantage parlor's basis for this claim
is that a termination of parlor's
account with amazon
will intentionally interfere with the
contracts parlor has with its
present users as well as the users it
was projected to gain
while their account was suspended now a
successful claim
under this tort requires the
establishment of several elements one
the existence of a valid contractual
relationship or business expectancy
to the defendant's knowledge of that
relationship three
an intentional interference inducing or
causing a breach or termination of the
relationship or expectancy
for the defendant's interference with an
improper purpose or by improper means
and five results in damage and here
parlor argued that amazon was well aware
of their current growth
and the potential for even more growth
highlighted by negotiations with amazon
to
increase server capacity and to
capitalize on the speculation that
president trump was going to join
parlor after being kicked off of twitter
and parlor argued that this
interference was intentional and
improper and used parlors purported
breach as a
just a pretext to ensure that parlor
wouldn't gain steam just at the time
they were likely to experience a
significant amount of growth
but yet again parlor leaves out the key
facts that are almost indisputable that
easily negate these allegations
especially as it pertains to the fourth
element
interference for an improper purpose or
improper means
interference claims cannot be made where
the alleged interference actions were
just
simply exercising of a contractual right
that someone actually has
it has to be improper and if you have
the contractual right to do something
that can't give rise to the tort of
intentional interference
and since amazon as we've already made
abundantly clear had the contractual
right to terminate this contract
basically immediately and improper means
can't be identified
as far as an improper purpose amazon
points out in its reply that
it would require amazon to have acted
out of greed retaliation or hostility
none of which was specifically alleged
in parlor's complaint now some of the
facts
go both ways in fact kicking parlor off
of amazon's platform actually hurts
amazon as well because they'd be
forgoing the revenue from parlor and
there are other things that go both ways
as well
like the fact that amazon was willing to
assist them by helping parlor migrate
their services to a different provider
and didn't hold back the data that was
presumably rightfully parlors
in a letter notifying parlor of their
suspension amazon stated quote
we will ensure that all of your data is
preserved for you to migrate to your own
servers
and we'll work with you as best we can
to help your migration
now those are parlor's three claims but
there's another aspect to this that i
think
bears mention at this point which is
that amazon has certain affirmative
defenses just because people
make accusations against you doesn't
mean that you can't use what's called an
affirmative defense to
throw out those claims even if those
claims happen to be true
and with so many things these days this
involves section 230 of the
communications decency
act and here much to the ire of
trump supporters everywhere amazon also
argued that in addition to all of the
other reasons that they provided that
parlor's claims just fail on their own
rights amazon is also protected by
section 230. this section explicitly
restricts liability against online
service providers in certain instances
when they block perceived harmful
content section 230
c2a specifically states that quote no
provider or user of an interactive
computer service
shall be held liable on account of any
action voluntarily taken in good faith
to restrict access to
or availability of material that the
provider or user considers to be obscene
lewd lascivious filthy excessively
violent harassing or otherwise
objectionable whether or not such
material is constitutionally protected
this good samaritan rule then provides
an additional layer of protection for
amazon
as a computer service company tasked
with the tremendous responsibility
of trying to provide a platform for an
informational resource
and political discourse while being
cognizant of the need to protect
individuals against harmfulness
information and illegal activity and as
we've talked about on this channel
before and we'll probably talk about
many times in the future section 230 was
a response to the early days of the
internet where
if a website did any kind of moderation
whatsoever
they were deemed to be constructively
knowledgeable about
all of the illegal stuff that was on
their website and so it was a way
to allow websites to do some moderation
without being liable for everything
that's on their website
this applies to amazon it applies to
youtube it applies to anyone that even
has
a blog that has uh comments
on it and if you didn't have this kind
of protection odds are
they wouldn't host anything on it
because they'd be too worried about all
of the illegal stuff that's hosted on
there so it's either
an all or nothing proposition where
there would be basically 100 moderation
and nothing
even remotely controversial or zero
moderation at all and it would just be a
complete wild west
so as you probably know the way parlor
started this lawsuit was a request for a
tro or a temporary restraining order
it's an emergency motion
to get someone to not do something it
started as a way to
try and prevent amazon from kicking
parlor off its platform and then
it was basically in order to demand that
amazon put the
app back on its platform and you can
imagine under some of these
circumstances where a tro might be
granted because
kicking a app off of a platform might
give rise to the kind of irreparable
damages that a tro
is meant to solve it's a very temporary
thing so you can get to the merits of
the litigation without
complete destruction that cannot be
undone but to get a temporary
restraining order
a plaintiff would have to establish
number one that it's likely to succeed
on the merits and as we've just
talked about that's definitely not going
to happen all three of its claims pretty
much fail
pretty easily number two that you have
to show that you're likely to suffer
irreparable harm in the absence of
preliminary relief
which in this circumstance probably
exists
having the app completely down the
website completely
destroyed and needing to be rewritten
for some other platform
yeah that could be irreparable harm
number three the balance of the equities
tips in its favor which
definitely doesn't exist here because
you can have all the irreparable damage
in the world but if you're not going to
succeed on the merits
you're not entitled to any relief if
you're not going to succeed and
finally the fourth element is an
injunction would be in the public
interest which
also for basically the same reasons
doesn't really exist here
now that being said this is not the end
of the lawsuit
contrary to a lot of media reporting
about this lawsuit
it's not over by any stretch of the
imagination in fact this is really just
the end of the first inning
parlor took a big swing they whiffed the
court didn't grant the emergency motions
for a temporary restraining order or the
preliminary injunction
but the lawsuit still exists and the
court is still going to have to
adjudicate these claims on the merit of
the claims and while
some preliminary evidence was provided
to the court
that we haven't gotten to the discovery
portion where they can
get a whole bunch of more evidence so
this lawsuit isn't going anywhere
generally if you lose the temporary
restraining order and the court says
you're unlikely to win on the merits
that's
a really really bad sign for the
plaintiff like parlor but
they still have the option of pressing
forward except that's not what happened
at all because i
am devin from the future because the day
that i was going to release this video
parlor decided to go ahead and
voluntarily dismiss their own case so
they dismissed their own case from the
federal district court in which they
filed
and this is one of those cases where
it's important to recognize the
difference between a dismissal with
prejudice and without prejudice we talk
about that a lot on this channel because
that is a common misconception if you
get dismissed with prejudice that means
you can never refile your case is done
it's over the only thing you can do is
appeal
but when you dismiss without prejudice
you can refile your case either in the
same court or potentially in a different
court if you have jurisdiction
and that's exactly what parlor decided
to do here having been
trounced in federal court parlor decided
to refile their case
in washington state court and that's not
an entirely unusual thing to do
often it's because you got smacked
around in a federal court that you
decide to
go to a different court there are times
when you can do this there are times
when you can't do this i'm not going to
go into those at the moment
and here parlor has slightly retooled
their case in potentially a more
favorable forum
they've added a few new claims the first
of which is a washington state consumer
protection act claim now
washington state along with a lot of
different states has a sort of general
catch-all
statute that doesn't allow businesses to
engage in what are considered unfair
business practices
but that requires an underlying
predicate unfair business practice and
they're going to have an uphill climb to
be able to prove that amazon engaged in
some sort of
uh unfair business practice against
parlor into it parlor claims that amazon
engaged in unfair business practices
along the lines of
forcing them to sign a contract of
adhesion and actually
hacking into their information or at
least leaving open the possibility of
getting hacked by other people
with respect to the contract of adhesion
that's probably legally going to fail
lots of times contracts of adhesion
meaning that you don't have any say in
being able to change the contract well
those are most of the contracts that
people engage in these days so
the fact that it's a contract of
adhesion alone doesn't mean it's against
public policy and with respect to the
hacking claim that may be legally
sufficient and that'll be a factual
dispute that the parties will just have
to litigate and furthermore parlor now
claims a defamation claim against
amazon asserting that amazon defamed
parlor by
alleging that parlor was unwilling to
moderate the content on its own site
and then partly reiterates a lot of the
same breach of contract claims that were
at issue in the federal case
though in the federal case they were
never adjudicated so it makes sense to
reassert them here
as we discussed in this video already
the evidence for these breach of
contract claims are pretty thin
and again it's going to be an uphill
battle but some of these claims may be
enough to survive a motion to dismiss
and in which case the parties will
probably engage in some discovery that
may get expensive but
again this is probably not the end of
the parlor case it's entirely possible
that some of their claims will survive
motions
to dismiss if they're able to get away
with changing the venue like this but
whether this parlor suit is in federal
court or washington state court this
suit probably isn't going to go away
anytime
soon just like working from home and
video conferencing is going to last
forever it seems like which is why it's
more important than ever to wear
comfortable clothes all day long and
you might have noticed i started a
series of daily video shorts called
eagle briefs and inevitably
people started demanding actual eagle
briefs so
here you go eagle briefs from mack
weldon because they are known for their
insanely comfortable boxer briefs
including their new stealth boxer briefs
that
is great for everything from working out
to hanging out and feels like absolutely
nothing at all
and if you're watching this channel
you're an adult and you probably deserve
to have nice boxer briefs and i can tell
you it makes a world of difference i
also love their radius pants which are
halfway between slacks and joggers
they're also extremely comfortable
for the man who can wear sweatpants but
doesn't want to
and if i'm not in court or on a zoom
call with a judge i'm often wearing mac
weldon they focus on smart design and
premium fabrics
i order in multiple sizes and have them
shipped and then just return the ones
that didn't fit right and keep the ones
that fit perfectly and if you want to
try their famous boxer briefs and if you
want to call them eagle briefs that's
perfectly fine too
you can try them out and if you decide
for any reason that you're not satisfied
you can just keep them
and still get a free refund because who
wants to return used underwear
so if you want to try mac welding just
go to macweldon.com legaleagle or just
click the link
in the description clicking on that link
really helps out this channel
so do you agree with my analysis leave
your objections in the comments and
check out this playlist over here with
all of my other real law reviews where i
talk about
the current legal issues of the day so
click on this playlist or i'll see you
in court